All right. So Charles, what do you think would some
reasonable resources to try to manage in a learning algorithm?
>> Okay, well I was thinking of three. Because three is my favorite
number. Two of them are what you already have written up there. Time and
space. After all, at the end of the day, it's still an algorithm.
We need to be able to analyze algorithms in terms of time and space.
>> That's right, so if in particular we have a learning algorithm and
they, they do more or less the same things, but one runs in n-squared
time and the other runs in exponential time, we'd really like
to have the one that runs in the shorter amount of
time. Or, in particular, if there's a, if we define a
learning problem and we say well, We could do this computation, but
its MP hard. Then maybe that's a problematic way of defining
the problem. So yeah, time definitely matters. Space for the same
reason. And those are the same things that happen in in,
or that are relevant in regular algorithms. What about anything specific to
the machine learning setting?
>> Okay, so that was my third one. So The only thing that
matters in machine learning or the most important thing in machine learning is
data. So I would think that another resource that we care about is
the data and in particular the set of training samples that we have.
>> Yes I like the, I like the word samples. Though data
is probably pretty good. Thing to stick in there as well or examples.
Those should all be okay.
>> Yes. Indeed. Yeah. We, we want to know, can
we learn well with a small amount of samples. In
particular if, our learning algorithm works great in terms of
time and space, but in order to run it you
actually have to give Examples of every possible input, then
that's not going to be a very useful algorithm. So,
the fewer samples that it can use, the more that
it's generalizing effectively, and the better it is at learning.
>> Oh, that makes sense.